a gente fala muito sobre a comida do
Futuro mas o que que essa comida que vai
alimentar milhões de pessoas que ainda
vão nascer o planeta terra está
preparado para isso eu sou agricultor e
passei os últimos seis anos tentando
introduzir biodiversidade na cadeia de
alimentos vamos falar sobre comida e
sobre o futuro
pelo olhar de quem está fora do cão a
gente fala muito de comida como um ato
político como a escolha que você pudesse
fazer e mudasse o mundo eu também sou
consumidor evitando essas premissas
ambientais como base tentando assimilar
as minhas escolhas como uma ação que
pudesse gerar algum Impacto e o tempo
consumir de maneira responsável e
contabilizar a minha Pegada Ecológica de
vendas minhas ações em diversos momentos
e fritar o fundo que acabei me tornando
agricultura cultivando os próprios
alimentos e oferecendo essa opção a
minha família mas mesmo assim eu ainda
sentia que havia algo descolado da
realidade porque afinal vamos lá qual é
a ti que mais gera Impacto sobre o
planeta que mais utiliza os recursos
naturais da terra é atividade de colocar
comida no nosso prato é agricultura
agricultura e a pecuária utilizam cerca
de 13 da superfície terrestre para
alimentar a humanidade hoje e colocar
comida na mesa tem sido maior
responsável pela derrubada de todas as
florestas no mundo e a pergunta que mais
me intrigava era Qual é esse real poder
de influenciar aquilo que está no meu
prato
a solução mais desejada é comprar direto
do Agricultor familiar a sua linda cesta
de alimento mas essa variedade de
alimentos é suficiente para você se
alimentar para você se nutre 365 dias ao
órgão não a gente não precisa fazer
compras no supermercado a gente não
precisa comprar produtos importados mas
por quê
Porque a gente aprendeu a consumir os
mesmos alimentos estão daqui ou do outro
lado do mundo eu morei no no Canadá e
nos Estados Unidos e o que a gente come
aqui não é muito diferente do que se
come lá
Quando você vai ao supermercado a oferta
de ingredientes a quadra mesmo a receita
pode variar o paladar Pode ser adaptado
mas ingredientes são basicamente os
mesmos eu viajei muito pelo Brasil
e toda vez que voltava de um país e toda
vez que ia voltar para o supermercado eu
me perguntava o que aconteceu a cada dia
que passa encontre menos um tipo de
espécie de planta na prateleira do Japão
não tem essa variedade de semente para
comprar aqui se você quiser validade vai
precisar procurar numa loja
especializado e na Europa a maioria dos
países também você não encontra esta
variedade mas por quê Porque a variedade
de ingrediente foi padronizada isso quer
dizer que todo sistema de produção de
alimentos mundial foi padronizado
consumimos as mesmas espécies de plantas
aquella oferecemos os animais as mesmas
variedades
e se você fizer uma lista com todos os
ingredientes que você já consumiu na
vida se você for eu precisar dor de
gastronomia Talvez você encontre
já tem experimentado cerca de 200
espécies mas para a maioria das pessoas
não passamos de sangue sendo que existem
cerca de 401 espécies de plantas
catalogadas com potencial de consumirmos
300 mil delas e segundo a fao mais de
mil espécies já foram domesticados para
agricultura e onde estão essas plantas e
quais são esses sabores quantos
nutrientes gente tá perdendo por conta
de uma dieta padronizada eu mergulhei
nessa vida de plantar e colher o meu
próprio alimento sempre pensando na
sustentabilidade do campo e para isso
precisa Inovar e porque aquilo é o seu
penso no futuro eu preciso gerar
impactos recentemente positivo para
oferecer esse futuro estado de os meus
filhos e falar em futuro sadio parece
simples mas a gente não tem ideia de
quanto o seu complexo
eu percebi que a resposta que todos que
era biodiversidade nós seria
biodiversidade no meu prato eu precisava
perguntar a biodiversidade e como é que
se planta biodiversidade como é que se
colhe biodiversidade e como as
implementam isso em solo degradado
porque o que encontrei foi solo
degradado Será que estiagem e do outro
lado não encontrei Floresta intacta
nessas duas condições como se planta
biodiversidade são plantas que a gente
não acha para comprar semente no
pacotinho não tem manual de instrução
para gente plantar o que a gente chama
de erva daninha mato traga e elas são
plantas nativas de cada bioma do Brasil
elas são árvores e elas são florestas de
pé ou elas são invasoras e precisam ser
controladas ou então adaptadas e é
natural que as plantas se adaptem se
reinventem para sobreviver
elas se tornam variedades nativas e
existem tantas plantas com tantas
características incríveis por aí
oclusivo e características necessárias
agropecuária no Brasil o país mais rico
em biodiversidade é uma riqueza que eu
não sei expressar o que eu sei é que eu
e meu companheiro a gente acaba se
tornando apaixonado por planta
alimentícia não convencional
e a gente aprendeu a domesticar espécies
selvagens aprender a respeitar biomas
interações entre plantas e espécies e eu
aprendi elaborar alimentos com essas
plantas de forma não convencional também
não tem laboratório na cozinha para
poder fazer com que essas plantas sejam
agradáveis ao Paladar e elas terem está
o tempo de prateleira que é tão
necessário comercialização e eu e ele a
gente aprendeu junto inserindo a
biodiversidade no campo a gente trazia
biodiversidade para o solo e a gente
entendeu que dava para estar ir viu da
gincana ao mesmo tempo que regenerável
solo e regional do solo a gente regenera
a água e regenera micronutrientes da
planta e planta bem nutrida com muitas
outras espécies de plantas na
alimentação Regional Nossa microbiota
intestinal que é tão importante nossa
saúde Então até aí a gente entendeu que
é biodiversidade mais agricultura era
sinônimo de vida era sinônimo de planta
estadia de solos tá de de água e de
saúde mas que a gente descobriu não
parou por aí existem muitas outras
pessoas que também querem uma
alimentação diferente Nossa uma busca
por sabores diferentes de um movimento
as pessoas também querem se alimentar de
algo nutritivo algo saboroso mas que
também faça bem ao planeta e o que a
gente em tese começou artesanal precisa
ser repensado em escalas maiores a gente
continua testando pesquisando muito
a gente aprendeu com a planta e a gente
entendeu que dava sim para trazer
biodiversidade na agricultura em escalas
maiores e até industriais e foi quando
eu vi que a indústria também não estava
preparada para lidar com ingredientes da
biodiversidade então a gente precisa
adaptar adaptar tudo já que toda a
cadeia produtiva de alimentos é baseado
em monocultivos desde as sementes até as
máquinas de plantação e colheita de
logística até o beneficiamento EA
comercialização de todo sistema
produtivo de alimentos é feita e baseado
aos monocultivos é esse resultado que a
gente tem hoje a agricultura como
atividade humana que mais gera impactos
negativos do planeta e como nós a
humanidade estamos lidando com tudo isso
se a gente olha para frente temos dois
grandes de Lemos Como alimentar uma
população em crescimento e como manter a
agricultura de monocultivos resistente
as mudanças climáticas
último relatório do ipcc que saiu esse
ano que órgão internacional de pesquisa
mudanças climáticas Foi no mínimo
imperativo já estamos vivendo as
consequências das mudanças climáticas
agora e o que se esperava acontecer em
2050 foi antecipado para 2040 a
impossibilidade da vida na Terra tal
qual conhecemos é para amanhã e que já
vivemos hoje é de segurança hídrica
alimentação desequilibrada quebra de
Safra imigração em massa por conta de
intempéries climáticas e uma possível
crise de segurança alimentar Global
não estou aqui para dizer que
encontramos a solução de todos os nossos
problemas como eu disse a resposta para
o futuro estádio é complexa Mas o que eu
gostaria de alertar a qual a
criatividade humana em observação da
natureza a gente Talvez possa reverter
tudo isso
biodiversidade mais agricultura pode ser
o caminho essas plantas que viram
alimentos saborosos que podem ser
utilizados em larga escala que regeneram
solo que são
elas também são mais resistentes às
mudanças climáticas elas também de mão
não muito menos uso de água e pesticidas
e foi preciso um trabalho de resgate
dessas plantas foi precisa esse
movimento de apaixonados como nós
plantas alimentícias não-convencionais
E ainda preciso de um trabalho imenso em
pesquisas e sinceramente nossas
respostas podem estar na observação da
natureza porque senão a vida nada Stereo
Porque que a agricultura deveria ser
precisamos dessa cadeia devido ao nosso
redor E se o mundo é biodiverso e o ser
humano é diverso o planeta cheio de
vidas vírus fungos bactérias insetos
animais é cheio de plantas e sempre
viver em harmonia porque acreditamos que
na agricultura seria diferente
Gostaria que vocês guardar 100 apenas
uma palavra Gostaria que meus filhos a
sua futura geração talvez nem tem
emprego e nem planeta guardasse apenas
essa palavra peixe pectivo uma
perspectiva de futuro necessária
extremamente necessário e que ela seja
baseado no equilíbrio da natureza com os
nossos corpos e que o ser humano busca
uma perspectiva de habitantes neste
planeta eu tive um planeta para viver a
minha geração pode dizer isso eu
gostaria que os meus filhos também
pudessem ter as mesmas condições de ter
um planeta para viver e isso é o mínimo
que a minha geração pode oferecer é o
mínimo que eu como mãe devo oferecer
então da próxima vez que você for fazer
compras que você fizer alguma receita
procure diversificar a sua dieta com
biodiversidade procura ingredientes que
façam parte da história das Comunidades
rurais e desenvolvam agrofloresta que
tem uma linha de extrativismo ou
agricultura regenerativa e que você
também participou das discussões sobre a
sustentabilidade da cadeia de alimentos
que a sua comida Plante o futuro porque
estamos literalmente comendo planeta e
temos muito pouco tempo para reverter
isso